two welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
number 27
in the united states and let's face it
that's pretty much the world
i am your host the fresh prince of dead
air my beautiful
co-host is not with me today she's at
the dentist
today's episode is sponsored by
draftkings thank you to them
um first of all before we get into it i
am tick tock famous
okay i want to tell you all straight off
the bat
and i don't want to like big time you
guys
but um i am tick-tock famous
i recently started posting a tick tock i
didn't understand tick-tock and now i'm
kind of a big deal i mean ab
you're like the resident tick-tock
master describe my
cat my media meteorotic meteor
meteoritic
meteor idiotic midi or idiotic
rise on tick-tock go ahead tell the
people
it's beyond words
you know what i've been browsing tik tok
a lot because first of all i'm
such a boomer and it's like the most
popular social media so i started
to really try to immerse myself in it my
tick tock is ethan klein
h3 you know i've been scrolling a lot
and
it gets kind of repetitive i feel like
my brain's rotting out a little bit
because
i started to see the same stories do you
have that problem
um you might be going through the people
you follow
or or it pushes similar content because
i was thinking there must be a
more diverse group of
creators there but anyway i came across
these these knuckleheads
let me show you guys this there's like a
whole sub genre of
of goons who just do this baba booey
meme
and to me that was the funniest [ __ ] on
the app i just every time i saw these
guys
doing baba bowie it made me want to make
my own so i made my own baba bowie and
we are currently sitting at
840 thousand views and everybody by the
way on tick tock hates me already
you said everybody on tick tock is nice
ab
no a lot of people are defending you oh
they are
it's funny because some people are
saying uh wow look at this old man
coming to the internet and then other
people are like well imagine not knowing
who ethan klein
is yeah i guess they're i guess they're
they're technically right though
because it is pretty cringy when i first
read this but it just
it makes no sense and that's why i love
it
[Music]
tick tock is my home it is my home i've
been feeling that lately
and you know people don't even know that
baba boy's from howard stern it's just a
weird sound bite that that trips me out
that people don't even know the origin
of that
yeah it's bizarre so um people
got angry at me they were calling me a
boomer saying i ruined the sound bite
and then and then so i made a response
video
people she said someone said wait are
people sincerely thinking this is funny
oh gosh so i had to
i had to come back
it doesn't make any sense it's so stupid
dan you dan hates it i [ __ ] hate it
why do you hate it so much i just
because it's it's so dumb it's pointless
the whole thing isn't that what's genius
about it
it's just it reminds me of like early
2000s
lol xd so random humor it reminds me of
like
new grounds or uh i don't know you think
it's that bad people were saying i was
doing lele pons content
well i'm not even saying specific to you
i mean you didn't
this isn't you didn't invent this like
you said this is already like a trend
and it's just i don't know there's
something about it
with the fast the speed and the baba
buoys
and the finger wagging it just it gets
me dan
anyway that's my tick tock and i'm
having a lot of fun over there tic toc
is my home
tic doc will never go away it might
by the time this wait this episode comes
out next tuesday
that's the 15th that's the deadline for
trump so by the time this episode hits
no this comes out on monday oh monday
okay so
but it's true that it's increasingly
looking more and more like tick-tock may
not be our home
for much longer because china's blue
balling and they may not
china may just block the sale straight
up because they're just like you know
[ __ ] america
yeah i love it we don't like it you know
i was thinking
is it like a high-level chess play for
china to block the sale to try to
because china hates trump because he's
just he's not like a reliable
partner and he's the whole kung flu
thing
so i wonder if this is a high-level play
to try to get the young vote out against
donald trump
because imagine all these kids tiktok is
my home
donald trump got tick-tock banned he
didn't he couldn't secure the deal some
it's some nobody likes me
four-dimensional chests it's it's
possible i guess
uh i don't know
because they were doing stuff like
they're they were targeting trump's base
when they were doing having like the
trade war they were like putting
taxes on soybeans and stuff to hurt like
the farmers farmers that support them
specifically to
target trump's it's i mean it's possible
i mean
this whole tick tock thing it's part of
the larger trade war it's true and so
it's it's not really
just about tick tock so um so yeah i
mean there might be an element of that
to it
who knows well anyway um
speaking of boomers on tick tock we
decided in
in celebration of me becoming a tick
tock celebrity is that we would
celebrate some of my contemporaries
there
and watch some other old people tick
tock segments
don't call myself a boomer okay boomer
but much like uh facebook old people
facebook and
and the likes there's tons of old people
on tick tock which always
shocked me because it's kind of
complicated
uh like all these old people just
figured out how to use tick tock somehow
and and i don't understand how they
figured it out before me
anyway this is one this guy just showed
up in my feed and
i've followed him and he's my one of my
favorite creators on tik tok
uh his name is david nappy four and he
just hates people from
england for some reason you think you
won didn't you
you think you won huh why because you're
from england
it doesn't matter i'm down to
107 pounds i'll probably 106. and don't
delete my videos
i didn't do nothing to you you just mean
because you're british
yeah it's because you're from britain
because you're english people you're
mean i did nothing to any of you but you
know what
everything's underway i don't have much
longer
so does that make you happy yeah that
was the first video i saw
and i was like wow this shit's crazy
it's just straight up showed up on my
home feed you just scroll and scroll and
scroll
and then you come across a gym like this
and the angle and he's talking right to
me
and he hates england i never i didn't
know that people hated
england just as a general they're like
[ __ ] english people
i didn't know that was a thing but this
guy's down with it
oh he's my favorite david
i hate the uk i hate the uk
i hate anthony i hate you all hate you
call them
you're in big trouble you don't know who
you're messing with
so from what i've gathered
is that there's a few people that troll
him in the comments
right right and and it really gets to
him
and like i feel bad that he's getting so
you know it's getting worked out i'm
just i'm just a spectator
um but
but he keeps going he posts quite
frequently hi this caption of this one
is i hate the uk it's ruined my life
wow i hate you i hate you
i hate you [ __ ] british [ __ ] i hate
you british sick
disgusting thing think you're tough
gonna make me miserable
well you know what i have something in
mind i'm good
i i hate you i hate you this [ __ ] is so
crazy
oh man he's he's by far the greatest
person like this is this is what's so
cool about tick this has 300 likes which
on tick tock is like a really
underground video
they just pop [ __ ] like that on your
feet they frequently show me stuff that
has like zero likes
just to be like what do you think about
this yeah i think it's fantastic how you
get the weird [ __ ]
i hate you i hate you [ __ ] british
[ __ ]
i hate you pretty sick just yeah look at
this
why does it always got to be so heated
all the time
why
it's plenty hot how y'all doing
see i'm not a man i'm an eight-year-old
boy
what's wrong with you all what see
i'm an eight-year-old look at me
[Music]
i'm telling
[Music]
yeah he picks the comments really
personally and so people are calling him
old i believe and that's why he's like
oh i'm an eight-year-old
oh okay yeah it's all about just
this guy's just currently at war with
his the people in his comments which is
just hilarious because i mean
it's great now he's much younger i used
to go
it's all coming back from the past
and also i think this is coming back
when i was in high school
the twitches you know you
had this twitches and people thought i
had tourette's
but it's just something i couldn't help
anything
yeah that guy's a legend and i think
you're pretty sure he's wearing like a
ponytail toupee
which is wild because he switched it up
here he's got different hairdos oh
you love it david nappy he's a legend go
show him love on like all these
bastards from the uk especially if
you're from the uk
yeah be like i'm english and we love you
here
we don't all hate you in the uk now he's
the best
some of his videos are happy though you
saw you having a good day there
miss patty cake so this girl's obsessed
with trump
and she only makes videos of her
twerking on trump and oh and then she's
also obsessed with um
mark cuban so
all of her content is just her twerking
on donald trump and such
she's trying to get it what are the
chances that trump sees this and is like
i need to reach out there yes i'll just
piss on the floor i said i love it
algorithm is pretty good
chrissy teigen gwen stefani
tupac shakar fetter womp
huh ella beezy
here we go get that
hey vin diesel what do you think about
um miss patty cake
how am i supposed to do this interview
look at this woman yeah she looks good
you're right
she looks good man oh my goodness
wow oh the whap challenge
don't show this to kyle the cougar champ
he'll lose his mind
yeah she's a legend bud the stud
oh no there's so many of these man it's
funny okay one two three go
are you ready yeah
does he have no teeth is that what's
going on
yeah it looks like he's coming he's
gumming hard
oh yeah that's you now oh
he didn't recognize himself
yeah bub the stud oh this is iconic
tick tock old people [ __ ] uh anthony
hopkins
made a dancing tick tock what the [ __ ]
yeah
he quit he went from westworld to
tick-tock bro oh boy
step down is there no audio i'll
probably have to i'm just
removed just in the beginning part
there's nothing there's a drake song
uh i mean how old is anthony hopkins
keep writing ladies look up his age
i mean that guy's got moves for an old
man let's not even hate on them
look at the slides and [ __ ] damn he's
still got it okay
he's 82. 82 hey mr stella
what can dr hannibal actor right give me
a party
huh and arnold so he's calling out
people but i i literally can't
understand a single word
like stallone and arnold but he's right
for me arnold
[Music]
i'll be
wow listen i love anthony hopkins one of
the greatest that ever did it but that
was bizarre it's very strange
but i love it you gotta love it
days in quarantine and i think i'm still
sane that's it
that's the video that's it freeze frame
yeah this one must have gone viral right
anthony hopkins
dancing dr phil is on tick tock of
course
begging people you have to not to call
him dad
daddy on all of my posts i ain't your
daddy
i hate to break it to you but it ain't
your daddy you notice how his dome is
all makeup
feelings i appreciate it like his dome
is
has so much makeup it's awesome because
you gotta because you see a makeup line
like right on his forehead
so you gotta go all the way with the
dome he's got a blend
he's got blend better he just went all
the way back the makeup line's probably
in the back of his head
you know he'd probably blend it into his
neck break it to you
but i ain't your daddy and i feel that
and died
i appreciate the support it's a little
weird but i do appreciate the support
[Music]
what okay it was like a slow motion
yeah that's some old that is that's some
old people take talk [ __ ] right there
i don't think he realized it was a
filter because he just acted it out
oh you're supposed to do a filter it was
like i mean yeah there's like a slow
motion effect
oh so but he just pretended to walk slow
yeah
that's awesome that's awesome okay
here we go again this is dr phil showing
his ignorance today but
i've been in quarantine so i'm spending
more time on
social media than normal so i've been
finding things that i have no idea what
the hell they mean come on guys you need
to give me a translation guide here's
one
simp s-i-m-p yeah it's like
i am a simp for dr phil um
josh besides i have no idea
dude he dude these are the best videos
on the internet he knows exactly what
he's doing these are the best
[ __ ] videos i wish i could just this
could be something
really dirty or something really stupid
i don't know
i need help give me some help
translation guide
please yeah i think honestly
i generally don't like dr phil but his
social media is pretty fire
so i am kind of sorry i am kind of
simping for dr phil
hey it's the dance sensation that's
taken all over the
nation it's the cookie dance
is this an original fad uh that he's
setting here a b or is he following a
trend boom
i believe he's doing it himself he has a
lot of content like that
houston we've got a problem
are you talking to me
i will say again these these people are
figured out tick tock before me
yeah i mean damn these people probably
can't even use email and yet they've
mastered tick tock
anyway you guys get the idea there's a
ton of them
um so shout out to old people tick tock
i gotta say i love tik tok now
i'm in and i am actually planning a sit
in protest in front of the white house
to protest
uh the shutdown of tick tock tick tock
is our home it's called the event
tick tock is our home i kind of i need
to make a tick tock using those sound
bites
that'd be great next up
travis scott is done for some reason
this huge mcdonald's collab which
everybody's going crazy about
and i i don't really understand why
i'd understand why people are going so
crazy about it the big thing is that he
has his own
combo meal now with mcdonald's
with a quarter pounder with shredded
lettuce and bacon
a medium french fry with barbecue sauce
and a medium sprite with extra ice this
sounds very much like anything that
already exists on the menu
uh well anyway ian went there this
morning because
the whole thing is you know tell him
cactus jack sent you who was cactus jack
by the way
i think it's just travis scott it's his
it's his nickname
so he sent mobs of people to mcdonald's
to tell him cactus jack sent you
so ian that's so [ __ ] up dude like
you know how they've just ruined the
lives of every mcdonald's worker
in the country so ian went and picked it
up this morning and he
well he just simply followed the
instructions
let's see how it went well
yeah cactus jack sent me
sorry cactus jack yeah
[Music]
uh medium sprite with extra ice
so yeah you why why you got to order
your own [ __ ] cactus jack sent you
no it didn't work did it work again
cactus
when you said cactus jackson or you kind
of had to clarify there
i mean they did know that that meant
travis scott
which is better than most of the clips i
saw online
oh this is this is something a lot of
people are doing yeah
i see how how are they usually reacting
just like what they're like what the
hell are you talking about
that's awesome captain jack sparrow
let's watch the commercial here get a
pipe
what's up world yeah you i'm travis
scott
this is my mcdonald's order follow me
here's my quarter pounder with lettuce
pickles onions ketchup mustard and bacon
here's my fries sometimes i do this
then i dip them into barbecue sauce oh
yeah and my sprite
same order since back in houston and you
could try too gotta go
i don't understand why do people
understand about this is like a very
normal meal isn't it
it's just a [ __ ] quarter pounder with
some fries
and then he gives you barbecue sauce
instead of
ketchup and lots of people do that so
anyway we've got it here so
let's see you know i know you guys love
to watch me eat
it's the best french french fries are
super stale by the way i don't know if
that's how he likes it
that's how they do it that's how they do
it in uh texas
you gotta hit with that barbecue sauce
yeah you're [ __ ] up and you gotta
hold it over your head first
what that's what he said in the
commercial didn't you see
hold the barbecue no no no the fry and
the fry
oh why did you do that i i couldn't tell
you
do you know why he does this well he is
there's like a meme of him holding a
microphone above his head so i think
that's what
okay got it
nope there's some crunchy ass fries
right now it's not like you're eating
carrots grunge dude holy [ __ ]
well you know what i'm not eating bread
or
cheese but i'm going to do this for
travis scott wow
do it do it for the captain or cactus
cactus
he's not a captain he's a cactus i know
a lot of people
have a cough mic you need a crunch mic
yeah can you chew a little closer please
i want to i want to feel it i like the
chewing sound i actually like it i do
too really
[ __ ] bomb you have to give me a break
we
you know we kind of got this more to
just demonstrate what the meal was it
wasn't
really the intent for you to to just sit
down and eat it
we're gonna have to cut this because i
just want to eat it
can you use your muffin for this next
bite can you give like a lot of emotion
big eyes for that thumbnail ooh
make it sexy now hold the burger up
now go whoa
okay perfect but i want food in my mouth
excellent excellent stuff this is
actually great i take it back go ahead
and eat it all because the more of this
you eat the
less likely it is that i'm going to have
to do the mayo on my head thing
[Laughter]
what what just saying i am good pose
yeah look at that
oh man that is thumbnail oh my god oh
hell yeah
working it's hot that's hot girl
that's hot oh yeah these guys are
get it i'm gonna eat this all we're
gonna have to cut it
all right you good to do that i'm sorry
yeah don't tell ela
don't tell ela nobody tell ela what
happened here today
hopefully she doesn't see that delete
the footage
[Laughter]
is there extra ice in there no no
there's actually very little ice
they [ __ ] you this is [ __ ] up aren't
you kind of playing yourself if you get
extra ice
what do you mean because you get less
drink yeah i mean down already puts too
much ice so
your ex were playing yourself i'm a nice
guy so i actually like it
you're a nice guy zach you're an angel
oh thank you baby oh
glorious yeah
okay where are we going with this that's
kind of pornographic i'm not gonna lie
i'm turned on right now yeah i'm
watching all of that i think trish is
not here
yeah oh my god what's the verdict on
that i mean it's just mcdonald's
i don't understand this whole branding
of travis scott it's a scam
it's a scam it's just mcdonald's well i
don't know if scam
that's just yeah i mean what's the scam
here
i could go to mcdonald's be like hey get
the ethan climb
it's a big it's a it's a big mac with a
small
french fry and medium ice get the ethan
klein
i'm gonna go to mcdonald's and ask for
the ethan clan tell him
tell them tell them the fresh prince of
dead air say yeah
it papa sent me the gerd gang
girl anyway let's look at the merch
because this is my favorite part it's
super expensive too by the way
which makes it all the better let's see
this one's like
just a mcdonald's shirt so it's fine
some of the stuff here is wild as [ __ ]
by the way i've noticed it's not sold
out are you surprised by that ian
no well no
because just you would always just
expect people to ride for this kind of
[ __ ] but like
jorts just straight up george with the
mcdonald's
on the back and it says cactus jack on
it
guess how much it is though 250. 250
dollars for mcdonald's shorts
250. i don't i think they must not have
sold any of these [ __ ] god you have
to be i'm sorry but you got to be a
[ __ ]
you really do uh ah
let's see those let's see the shirts
anyway so you got 250 jords
you've got uh let's see
oh and then of course the chicken nugget
plus you which is probably debatably the
maybe the only good item
i want that so bad you have no idea why
it's yours for 90
ships and ships in nine to 12 weeks bro
zach why do you want that so literally
you literally won't even get it for
three to four months
but can you imagine like sleeping you
know when you have your cappy on a
[ __ ] nugget
yeah i feel like i'm gonna wake up and
my face is gonna be all greasy
it's like the worst thing to put your
head on like big nuggets the whole day
people love you zach i don't think you
understand
that just makes everything sound cool oh
well thank you no i want it
[Laughter]
uh what was my favorite one like this
one just has the menu on it
50 bucks hey it's me captain jack
imagine walking around quarter pounder
with cheese lettuce bacon
medium fries and bbq sauce and a medium
sprite
extra ice apparently the whole medium
sprite extra ice we were talking about
is just
it's just lean which is awesome because
mcdonald's is basically just be like
hey all you got to do is pop in the uh
cough syrup and now you're and now
you're all ready to go sip that lean
get [ __ ] up
i've been [ __ ] up on cough syrup
before like i got like you know
you get it when you're sick and yeah it
doesn't really do it for me i don't
understand people
did you hallucinate no maybe i didn't
drink enough
clearly if you're supposed to
hallucinate the thing is i
i drank like a couple of good swigs and
just got a terrible stomach ache and
never did it again
yeah captain jack was not down that day
you need it with that sprite well there
you have it
travis scott mill just six dollars sake
actor jack sent you
yeah say captain jackson they did and
they said
what oh
and then of course he had a massive meet
up at mcdonald's which is
now turned into a hot spot let's see
this is at
uh oh my god
[Applause]
screen it where was this
[Applause]
well these people people love him man
travis scott yep
it's a new hot spot wherever that is
jack
himself all right speaking
before we move on uh it's break time
we'll be right back
if you love sports then there is
no better way to make it more fun and
exciting than draftkings
the leader in one day fantasy sports
to add to this week's excitement in
sports draftking has
millions of dollars in total prizes up
for grabs
and if you have not tried draftkings yet
head to the app store
now because you don't want to miss this
uh this is how it works okay it's simple
you pick your lineup
you stay under the salary cap you see
how your team stacks up against the
competition
nothing asks the excitement of watching
the game quite like having a shot
at millions of dollars and prizes
draftkings has paid out
billions of dollars to winners since
2012 so they know a thing or two
about cold hard cash fantasy sports
actually seems really fun it makes me
wish that i cared about sports
because i hear people who do it they
have like all the it's like so crazy
they have all these leagues with their
friends and these fantasy sports teams
and uh it seems like even more fun than
the actual game i feel like people just
watch sports so they can do their
fantasy teams now
it's true i've got several friends who
do that do you do any do you do fantasy
i don't myself but i have a bunch of
buddies that are super into it and none
of them were even into football
before the fantasy stuff that's what got
them into it a lot of my family members
do it
yeah i'm thinking about just watching
sports because fricking
i want to participate in the action yeah
download the draftkings app now and use
code h3h3
for a limited time new users can get a
free shot at millions of dollars in
prizes this week
don't miss out on the week 2 action
enter code h3h3
to get a free shot at millions of
dollars in prizes
with your first deposit that's code h3h3
only at draftkings make it rain baby
minimum
a five dollar deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply
see draftkings.com for details
ian what is the general reaction been to
the uh
the big mac mail are people loving it or
is it all
just kind of a goof especially with the
merch i i can't tell if people genuinely
like it or if it's like
getting clowned on i don't think people
really like it
but the marketing i think is working
incredibly well yeah for mcdonald's
mcdonald's like i'm gonna ruin this man
and i think the fact that it's just so
bad has become
hugely entertaining for a lot of people
so it's just become this big goof
100 billion percent mcdonald's is coming
out of this
huge and i think i think your boy travis
scott
is looking like a like a bit of a
ding-dong especially with that merch my
god and he's selling it directly it
seems like he just
licensed that part from mcdonald's
he has like a history of kind of shitty
merch too
okay i mean he just did that huge uh
fortnight
merch collab like really months ago oh i
got to see that travis
scott fortnite merch and it was
notoriously bad
it's pretty goofy it's not as bad as
this but also he
he brands everything he sold um
like cigarette light uh ashtrays
with fortnite travis [ __ ] on it
is this it this is kind of dope what is
this
yeah that's one of them that's sick
that's way cooler than a [ __ ]
mcdonald's jorts mcdonald's george is
the worst
literally the worst merch anyone's ever
made
for 250 bucks dude
you can't top that no one will ever beat
that in terms of bad merch
all right let's move it on speaking of
hot spots thank you to travis scott by
the way
for creating a hot spot at that
mcdonald's
thank you cardi b uh sturgis we've
talked about that there was a huge
motorcycle rally
at sturgis we were smash mouth performed
there was 250
000 bikers who came and nobody was
wearing max
smash mouth famously said [ __ ]
coronavirus just to update
refresh your guy's memory
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody wants coughed in my mouth and
now i'm dead
and i killed my whole family
she was looking kind of short on breath
and then she
i was feeling it i don't like it trump
wasn't feeling it
well anyway listen to this [ __ ] we're
all joking about how it's a hot spot and
yada yada
listen to this a current study concluded
that
that the sturgis motorcycle rally in
south dakota
was a super spreading event that led to
an estimated 12.2
billion in public health costs
oops 12.2
billion just so smash mouth could sing a
shrek song to a bunch of [ __ ]
bikers you know it's funny i saw a clip
of
of smashboth performing and nobody
bikers don't care about smash mouth do
they
because he was up there performing like
you know
no they they don't care about smash yeah
i mean it's such a weird thing
hey i'm one of you
well the years start running and they
don't start coming to the meltdown then
they hit the ground running
yeah nobody was paying attention it's
concluded that 266
000 cases were tied to the event
that is [ __ ] incredible i also heard
it was like 25
of all cases in the united states for
the month was
was uh connected to sturgis
i mean it's pretty incredible they all
ride in on their motorcycles
from out of town get the
kovid and then they ride back to
wherever they're from and they it
becomes a super spreading event
in fact the friend of the show andrew
callahan
from all gas snow breaks was at sturgis
and he had some really great interviews
that i think would
help pepper rather dot the vibe that was
there
for example this this brave man here
rather die than wear a mask relax this
is a
false flag flu it's a pandemic masks do
nothing
it's the key people on fear while you
have all these liberal democrat states
trying to pull a socialism switch on us
what happens then well we know what
happens look at venezuela i'd rather die
i'm not wearing a mask i mean i hate to
say it but
look what happened to the jews whoa what
what happened to the jews what does that
have to do with anything yeah
i love how he goes i'd rather die
because there's a good chance he may
i didn't think they were being put on
trains to go and do what happened
people whoa oh my god
what the hell does that have to do
the masks are gonna kill us so
he's comparing wearing masks to jews
going to the gas chamber right i'm just
i mean the meta or like the comparison
is that the jews got on the trains not
knowing they were being led to their
death
being putting on the mask was going to
lead to dying
yeah because you you die of oxygen
deprivation apparently
people just be dropping dead they're
being used like human puns
then you've got the education system
teaching all of our kids
that it was built on the backs of slaves
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's over
what we're debating even that now
slavery never happened slavery is a myth
created by the liberals
well he's he's not a holocaust denier
but he is a
slavery dude you gotta you gotta deny
something
right the jew hater and the slavery
dinner
i love dude that's a new levels of
conspiracy i've never heard of
slavery denial he's probably not denying
that it happened but i think he thinks
that it
didn't matter or at all
or something i'm pretty sure it was a
nice little boost yeah
to own human beings right
man this guy's a legend i i wish he was
in charge of the education system
he's got some good ideas california
is like a third world country i spent a
hundred hours a week on the freeway
people are scared to death and the sheep
are waking up slowly
the silent majority is already speaking
it's our country again
you know what i mean i've been dead four
times i'm not afraid to die
sorry so yeah these are the kinds of
people out there this guy's been dead
four times apparently however that works
i always hear people say that they say
when your heart stops
you die but that's not true i feel like
you die
if you die you die do you know what i
mean
people say i my heart stopped beating i
was dead
uh-huh yeah aren't you dead or is it
until you're declared dead by a doctor
i think dead means you're [ __ ] dead
well but when you die your heart stops
though no yeah but you say no
yeah but if your heart stops it doesn't
mean you're dead because he's alive
they can revive you you're saying death
is not a reversible
process and so therefore if he is alive
currently yes he never
died right i mean most people i think
most people would say
death is defined by like your brain
probably a
culmination of things heart stopping
brain function
ceasing to function but people say i
died
yeah i mean never you're not dead people
say you're like on the operating table
and
and i technically died for two minutes
but you hold me back or whatever
and i say no you're alive you didn't
technically die
all right i got a scenario for you nikki
sixx the bass player from motley crew
had a hot shot of heroin died for seven
minutes
what do you mean he died for seven
minutes he was pronounced dead
in the ambulance for seven minutes is he
dead or did no
he's not dead he's alive but he died
though how can you
but he how can you die if he's alive
zack
he died for certain no his heart stopped
his heart stopped
but he died so to legally be dead
he's resurrected from the dead what do
you mean he died he died for seven
minutes and then came back
his heart stopped zach but he was
pronounced dead
all right we're going in circles here
just watch that mountain
netflix i don't like it
you can't die you can't die and then be
alive
all right fair point by the very
definition of death let's define death
here we go this is gruesome right let's
drill down on this right now real quick
the action of dying or being killed the
end of life
yeah that sounds pretty final
the end of life right so is his life
over zach no
i mean i guess you have to ask him
though but no he's he's very much alive
there you have it i think this one's
irreversible
when it stops beating and it's
irreversible okay i see what you're
saying
there you go we've come to we've come to
a consensus this is nice okay
so we all agree he's he is very much
alive
sure uh man let's see here's another guy
from the
sturgis they're telling us what to do
where to go shopping where to go out
when not to go out what to wear when you
go out
[ __ ] they can take sports and stuff
stuff them up their ass
because if they're going to kneel for
the american flag and i have no use for
these people at all
what do you think should happen to them
they have that right we fought
so they had that right i listen black
lives matter white lives matter
every life matters americans matter if
they start saying americans
matter i think we'll be a lot better off
everyone in this country
deserves the right to live the way they
want to live
the creepy music
i love him man this place is so wild you
are uh doing his show next week right
um next wednesday i believe we'll be
doing his podcast he's just launching a
podcast so we'll be going to his rv
he'll be sanitizing it for us and uh he
was just tested negative
actually he told me he has the
antibodies because he's like a walking
coronavirus petri dish right
he said he had it in february right when
he was on the show
he said he thought he had it but he
tested positive for the antibodies so
gender reveals are now the new it's just
a prank bro
um the
massive wildfire going on in california
was started by gender reveal
which funnily enough isn't even the
first brush fire
caused by gender reveal in the same week
this week
a woman was killed by gender reveal
an explosion just domed her or something
and now all of california is on fire
from a gender reveal
it was a boy by the way in case anyone
was wondering
but here's someone doing a gender reveal
on home depot just to kind of
get us started here it's awesome
can you guys explain what's happening is
it kind of confused here
like someone blasts him with blue and
then someone throws glitter on this guy
i don't get it
what's happening
nobody seems happy you don't do gender
reveals in home people out of the store
it's a generalization why
it's just a prank bro because he made
this huge [ __ ] mess there's glitter
everywhere which
is a nightmare to clean imagine
responding why
to that statement it's just a prank bro
you don't want gender reveals at home
people out of the store
how do you answer that i mean how do you
confront such such
stupidity why i don't know the way he
says why
it's really fun can somebody explain to
me he got
he got the blueprints the blue it's a
boy no but why did this guy get doubts
and gold glitter because because it's
super epic
you see yeah why did that happen these
aren't necessarily
the sharpest tools in the shed as our as
our friends in smash mouth would say
they're not an explanation for why they
threw a bucket of glitter
damn was that a pun you just said
because they're at home depot and they
sell tools there
not the sharpest tool in the shed i'm
not the sharpest tool in the shed
now it's all tied together there's a lot
of
there's so many layers to my humor it's
just
dan you are an extraordinary specimen
um i can't does anyone have a theory on
the glitter
i don't know what to tell you it's just
stupid
it's all stupid and we're talking about
a guy who when he was told you can't
do a gender reveal in home depot his
response was why
but the other guy has a boy
so why did the guy who's not even having
a kid get glittered
it's all part of the celebration it's
just
just excitement all around so these are
the types of people who are doing gender
reveals in general
and now let's go to the el dorado fire
which is the
brainchild of another one of these
geniuses
captured earlier today we want to talk
about evacuation orders because of
course that's what's on everybody's mind
out here
the following communities are under a
mandatory evacuation order forest falls
there's like two scenes there's like a
snap cut where it's like
it's a boy this is like a scene from
it's always sunny
it's a boy and then it cuts to this
mountain home village thousands of
people being evacuated tonight
el dorado fire is ravaging california
the whole thing is so insane who cares
who cares what gender the baby is the
real problem of course is that
you know it's so hot and dry from
climate change that
if you [ __ ] rub a couple of twigs
together the whole state catches on fire
so while it's extraordinarily stupid
these gender reveals
it's really uh these fires are going to
keep happening more and more as
as our climate continues to get more and
more [ __ ]
and you know today in california there's
a fire there's a new fire now el gato
where is that
is that like north of here where is that
i can't even keep track of them anymore
there's so many there's i know there's
no fire
in l.a the bobcat one is oh bobcat
that's the one i was referring to
yeah i mean that one is uh near pasadena
so it i mean that's not technically
ellie but i'd call it close enough yeah
so now there's another fire the bobcat
fire and like it looks like night time
right now in the middle of the day
because it's so smoky
you got do you guys see all these images
from san francisco or do we have that in
here yeah
uh let me see i don't know if it's in
the talk but
let me see the pictures yeah i remember
uh i remember seeing skies like that
here
once but there's no fire in san
francisco this is just their whole
their whole what's pretty close to san
francisco city is [ __ ]
it looks like this i mean this is just
normal
fall weather now ah
cool i'm starting to get scared i'm
getting really scared you know
over the summer we had the hottest day
in l.a history was 120 degrees in
woodland hills
in los angeles that ain't right that
type of weather is not
right
that was your first like how was that
for you ab because you kind of just
moved here and then you're getting like
the hottest day ever
yeah you know coming from detroit it's
uh very different
i was staying in orange county so it
wasn't as bad but when i came to the
valley
it was a whole nother ball game yeah it
cooled down a lot there were just two
days where it was
unfucking believable i mean it was the
hottest day in recorded
history in l.a here's beautiful san
francisco ah
you love to see it so i don't know i
mean
i'm i'm getting very worried about
climate change and while
covet is obviously a pressing issue it
will go away eventually but this [ __ ]
is uh we have no we have no remedy we
have no plan
we are unorganized the government is
even i mean even our president refuses
to
acknowledge that's even an issue that's
even happening
it's so many people like i made a tweet
about it the other day
and people go we're just going through
natural natural cycles the
climate of the earth changes all the
time
which is just some which is true but
that's not what's happening
you know that's just literal propaganda
to what ends to what end why like hello
we're all going to be affected by the
by this weather crazy hurricanes
in the south and eastern seaboard
crazy fires on the west coast extreme
weather is being
exacerbated
papa john called it why don't people
listen to papa was he behind it perhaps
i mean those pieces those fires you know
those pizzas put out a lot of
carbon you think it's all the pizza
pizza pizza ovens i love people
i love pizza and i love killing people
this is his and
and the anyway i don't i don't know man
i think we need a new green deal that's
my thing bro
i think we need it now now
we need it now
right right
thank you this year is just
crazy 2020 is kind of the worst year on
record for us
it's a hell of a [ __ ] year i mean a
one in a hundred year pandemic
combined with
social unrest fires combined with um
cactus jack
cactus jack merch drops yeah combined
with the fact that
boomers aren't tick-tock uh combined
with the fact that you know
i can't get my pool heater above 75. oh
[ __ ] i hate when that happens it's
terrible that sucks man
smoke generating pyrotechnic device
caused the fire
started at 10 a.m on september 5th
it's since grown to 9 000 acres
it's the second massive brush fire
started by a gender reveal party
i love that it's not the first man
that's so good
yeah there there's a recently uh we
discussed last year
there's actually footage of this one
starting
i mean what are the what are you doing
they have an explosive and dry brush
yeah so this is yeah
that's hot yeah literally
it's a boy and let's get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah that wasn't even like a little
thing where it's like oh [ __ ] some
brushes on fire they're like nah let's
just light this [ __ ] up
awesome um
i just don't get it what's the big deal
oh there was even a plane crash
bro from a gender reveal party
texas plane crash gender reveal goes
wrong he was crop
dusting blue or pink water
over texas and this [ __ ] crashed
thankfully he survived apparently the
pilot
by the way the city is called turkey
texas it's confusing as hell
this woman in iowa died from explosion
what are they what did they do like a
they carpet bomb a neighborhood with
blue paint and nails and [ __ ]
56 year old woman pronounced dead at the
scene
a gender reveal announcement resulted in
an explosion the woman was struck by
flying debris
this is straight up shrapnel
damn you know world war ii was actually
just a huge
gender reveal party for uh for truman's
first
son truman's the one that dropped the
nukes right
uh yeah yeah fdr and truman it was a big
gender reveal party for that for their
kids
yeah it's a big deal
so little known facts about world war ii
i did not know that yeah
and sadly tragically
one might even say the kardashians
keeping up with the kardashians the end
of an era
i when i heard this news i i got to my
knees and
wept in sorrow the kardashians
are no more the show has been cancelled
this is tragic it's tragic ian how do
you feel about that the whole
the whole family is no more yeah they're
well they had their
part of their contract is that they have
e needs a new family so they have to
incinerate themselves
as to not compete it's a non-compete
clause i see
that's tough and did you ever watch uh
kardashians
uh i never did but i know zach did
actually
zach you were a fan of every [ __ ]
thing dude tell me why i used to
i used to go to school with kendall and
kylie so really
yeah they left when i was in like ninth
grade wait were they they never they
didn't used to be like mega
rich superstars did they no they just
were always
you know they were humble and you know
we would talk sometimes but i wouldn't
call his friend
and what wait so which one did you go to
school with kendall and kylie
kylie is like a month older than me
and were they popular in high school uh
yeah
they were and did you want to [ __ ]
kendall back then
i wanted to [ __ ] kylie tell you the
truth oh really yeah
because kendall's the superstar now
uh she's the model right yeah yeah yeah
you could say that
she's too skinny for your taste yeah a
little bit mm-hmm
oh ellie's more famous now though yeah
i'd say so
kyle i think kendall's more famous no
kylie's the one that's the billionaire
yeah who's the one in the water video
yeah but yeah i used to watch it
so uh this one's dedicated to you here
let me read that try to hold back your
tears zach if you can i'm gonna read the
instagram announcement okay i don't need
to see zach full screen anymore
let's get some sad music going zach
yeah go ahead and something wistful
it is with a heavy heart that we've made
the most difficult decision as a family
to say goodbye to keeping up with the
kardashians
you see we asked eve for and i
say this with peace and love and
accuracy a hundred million dollars
[Music]
to do a new season yes 100 million
dollars
peace and love peace he said are you out
of your [ __ ] mind
and frankly we've outgrown the show
because we're all trillionaires now
we've used
we've used eve and frankly the audience
for every last bit of
juice we can
[Music]
and so with that being said goodbye
with a heavy heart of course
[Music]
the offer is still on the table if you
can find a hundred million dollars
by the end of the year we will come back
even though our ratings have fallen
from 5.8 million in the first season to
1.6
in its most recent episode and by the
way
how many youtubers get 1.6 million views
on a video
where's my hundred million dollars i
pull that on my videos i don't get
[ __ ] isn't that crazy where's my hundred
million i'll be a kardashian i'll give a
[ __ ]
i gotta i got to ask fat as kim and it's
natural
maybe fatter all natural yeah
and unlike kim i am willing to sell my
used underwear
damn i would like to eat that ass so in
celebration of the
of uh the kardashian ending
[Music]
i want to go ahead and look at this
article
um i find it interesting how much
they've changed over
the course of of the show kim kardashian
for example i mean she didn't change
that much honestly her body is all
[ __ ] crazy now
i'm not trying to insult the woman but
her ass looks like
her ass looks like she got like
her like she got she got trapped in a
radioactive chamber just her ass
the rest of her body was spared like
it's
so mutated and [ __ ] up
it's an interesting analogy you know
what i mean like her ass got super
powers
or some [ __ ] or just got like all puffed
up
yeah i got the gamma rays
courtney kind of looks the same no
comment there eh
this one cracks me the [ __ ] up
girl who are you trying to kid i mean
what is this that's not even the same
person i mean
it is so what's happened did she get is
this just a crazy photoshopping though
no no she's she definitely had the most
surgery of them i think she looks like
that well
i mean it's like lip injections and nose
job and her nose
super thin man i wonder if you can even
breathe out of a nose that thin
well there you have it girl you looked
totally fine before which is the one
that you wanted to [ __ ] uh you went to
school with them right zach
yeah uh kylie i went to school with
kendall and kylie but kyle's
kylie chris looks identical god bless
her
this one how did she again this isn't
this looks like a different person what
happened here
is that a plastic surgery thing or just
a glow up uh i imagine but also i mean
they were really young when it started
so they aged the most
over the course of it as well i'd
imagine
they were like teenagers when it started
right yeah i guess she was really young
yeah
this was 12 years ago now she's like i
don't know 25.
that's crazy yeah kylie's the one you
wanted to have sex with zach
yeah she used to like walk by school and
she used to smell so
good like there was this like
like aroma of just like holy [ __ ] like
he's rich so well hold on was she rich
at the time
or was because she wasn't a car like she
wasn't like a kardashian yet but
well she was a kid in their family yeah
i mean she wasn't famous yet but like
wow she was fake she was she was fam i
mean the show was like a season
early on oh so she was already famous so
she was kind of talk of the school
already yeah yeah yeah
and then uh yeah she used to have this
like just
aroma to her in this yeah
it was such a so when you have such an
experience
so when you would walk by her would you
breathe deep
sure you could say that you go you try
to catch like her draft
yeah exactly james class
walking up the stairs anything dude you
ever sniff her seat
no never did that do you ever try to
talk to her
yeah well i mean we talked i wouldn't
say we were friends but you know we
would talk in passing
were you trying to see if she was maybe
interested in you
yeah but there wasn't a shot in hell
back yeah [ __ ] high school
right not a [ __ ] there's not a shot
now now
don't say that zack it's come on believe
in yourself man
so she was hot back even back then
you're saying
i thought so yeah yeah well she wasn't
necessarily hot she just smelled good
according to him
oh no she was hot she was hot got it
that's not her future
yeah exactly well hopefully if she's
listening to this podcast and there's i
mean we are number 27 in the united
states
big fan yeah then zach i hope so lost
connection
i smelled you back in high school yeah i
didn't know if you remember me
hit me up kelly what did she smell like
just good perfume just
like flowers and like like um
like like people used to have like um
like locker
spray like and it just smells like
flowers and
it just smells like chick like it's just
a it's a nostalgic smell a nice chip
locker remember do you remember any
conversations you had with her
um we had a class together
and she like helped me with my math
homework one time what
she came over to your house or some [ __ ]
no no no no no no
no it wasn't anything like super deep
like that but yeah
it was um we had conversations but i
wouldn't call his friends at all you
think she would remember you if you ran
into her
probably not now yeah that's a shame
hey dan can you censor whatever weird
shit's on the sidebar what the [ __ ] is
this
look at this [ __ ] wait
[Music]
i don't know you see this the kovichin
no the dreamers ad or whatever the [ __ ]
the most erotic movies
that'll fulfill all possible sexual
fantasies you've ever had
that's the headline oh it's
the the yupe whoop website's really uh
the scoopwoop website scoop
and of course rob so uh oh yeah and then
you know bruce
became caitlyn interestingly enough he
has the least amount of or so
i'm sorry she has the least amount of
plastic surgery
with anyone in the family it's a little
ironic yeah
you might be right yeah i mean she's
looking pretty good she's looking pretty
natural
that is it you guys and the reason why
this episode is
shorter than usual one hour we're trying
to go exactly for here
is because we have premiering tomorrow
the first ever episode
of our should i say what we're doing or
what i was just gonna say
our our fourth episode of the week is is
coming out
tomorrow so starting tomorrow we'll be
doing four
episodes every week so we're reducing
the
amount of time of each episode to one
hour exactly
i'm trying to do so that's what we can
make exactly
what exactly is like
exactly well it's trying to get as close
to one hour as possible there you go
so that uh you know the other reason is
because the analytics i'm trying to get
some useful data
and when it's when the amount of time
varies so much it's really hard to get
any info about like
retention and watch time because i'm
trying to figure out kind of you know
what kind of what segments people like
to watch what keeps people's attention
it's really hard to figure that stuff
out
but besides that as we try to ramp up to
five
episodes per week i think we need to go
down to
exactly one hour episodes more or less
to
um because there's just no way we can
sustain that much content
you know that long of episodes so that's
it we're gonna try this new thing of one
hour episode so
with that being said i hope you've
enjoyed our first one hour episode of me
flying
solo it felt like the worst episode i've
ever done what do you guys think was
this the worst episode
no we've done worse which ones have been
worse do you recall any
the drunken pewdiepie one comes to mind
as my
worst episode ever
yeah i i yeah okay yeah that's probably
worse yeah i think there was a lot of
bad episodes around that time like yeah
but hey that's why we're here right they
said we'd never come back
they can't all be bangers you know yeah
does that well if you made it this far
you don't care that much anyway right
um anyway but tomorrow i'm very excited
so i hope you guys join us then
all right so stay tuned we love you
appreciate you and we'll see you next
time